la lutte était un profond thanh nien
à plusieurs on dirait que ça a été fait
pour vous c'est vraiment été fait pour
vous non pas du tout mais pas du tout si
tous vraiment c'était entre les mad
annick blancheteau qui a pensé à moi
pour le rôle
c'est vrai qu'elle n'est pas l'opposé de
moi parce que je crois qu'on a la même
carrure énergie peut-être force il ya de
la force c'est mal mais après non je ne
suis pas allée j'aurais pas si j'étais
elle un peu plus je crois mais il ya
déjà longtemps 10 15 ans et c'est ce qui
fait que je peux retrouver la jouer là
c'est les choses sont des choses à
retrouver sinon je l'aurais mal joué je
pense où ça m'aurait dérangé j'aurais
pas suivre même ce que je jouais là je
vais me balader dans des endroits qui
font plus qu'ils sont fermés chez moi
c'est une pièce qui était monté très
rapidement donc oui c'était bien aussi
parce que sinon moi je crois pas c'est
ce que j'ai lu ça m'a fait un peu jamais
eu la même sensation avec le film
marylin le tout revenant je suis allé au
bout d'un voyage seul d'un voyage de ce
voyage de dix ans avec un bonheur
commande pas quand on a la chance de
seul devant 4000 personnes chez les
hommes on est entre le rock n roll on
sait même plus c'est du théâtre ce qu'en
même temps on travaille ça comme du
shakespeare
c'est un truc magnifique ça mais bon une
phrase un rire c'était une pression que
je m'étais mise le temps passe moi j'ai
plus de dix ans plus aussi donc j'essaie
et je vais aller vers j'ai évolué et que
mes personnages ne peuvent pas être les
mêmes
et puis faire des choses seulement parce
que ça marche ne me paraît pas une bonne
raison
ça peut durer ou pas ou vous revenir
dans la figure donc donc là c'est en
tout cas c'est parfaitement
effectivement exacte avec ce que ce que
j'ai envie de faire c'est ce que
j'aimerais c'est pouvoir aller là dans
l'émotion gardien de rire élargir
l'éventail voilà parce que je peux pas
une phrase un reer j'adore mais pas con
pas content pas toute la vie parce que
je vais mourir
et puis pour même autre chose que parce
que je fais rire l'autre un gros carton
la classe je suis sûr qu'on ne s'ennuie
pas dans cette ville ça j'en suis sûr la
pièce est forte nous forons s'identifier
à la mer un moment à la fille à la soeur
a moins on connaît ça et puis ça renvoie
à notre propre famille on est enfermé
avec eux dans ses stations-service et on
peut pas ne pas le dire en sortant
obtient et moi où j'en suis avec ma mère
ce que ça traite de ça aussi qui est
quand même il ya dossier sur les mers
camp mais non là on a tous à plus ou
moins je sais que j'ai vu début de
l'émission c'est un peu compliqué c'est
différent moi je sais pas quoi dire dans
ces cas là c'est la pudeur en même temps
c'est enfin que la fête continue
oui